4,8 millions là c'est un hack c'est un
beau démarrage c'est derrière France 3
quand même qui cartonne encore avec 5
millions mais sachez que sur les moins
de 50 ans ils ont fait 49% de pénias
donc voilà donc ça c'est le double de ma
singer le double de Danse avec les stars
voilà je vous le dis Danse avec les
stars mastinger tout ça c'est pas chez
nous donc je ne peux que peut me réjouir
voilà donc c'est très bien 49 % je suis
très heureux pour le groupe très heureux
pour TF1 enfin moins mais voilà je suis
très heureux pour voilà pour tes temps
je suis heureux voilà donc ils sont
contents voilà ça a très bien marché tac
je sais je comprends rien ces chiffres
mais bon voilà merci donc voilà baissé
donc les chips c'est plutôt pas mal
après les chéris on va revenir donc sur
tout ce qui s'est passé et c'est l'heure
du débrief on va parler évidemment de ce
retour les loups qui a eu lieu samedi
soir sur TF1 les loups alors non on va
revenir sur comment ils ont démarré
l'émission l'ouverture du prime et c'est
vrai que l'ouverture du prime j'avais
l'impression
que c'était pas mal
et après et après j'ai cru qu'on était à
la fête de l'école regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la Star Academy est de retour une star
ac nouvelle génération nouveau corps
professoral nous vos élèves mais
toujours la même soif de musique de
spectacle
[Applaudissements]
absolu de Coldplay qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
forts Chris Martin et Maryline darka
bonjour Christmas au début de TPMP je
suis invité sur le gros journal Le grand
journal ou pas tu es sur Canal+ à
l'époque on était et donc il m'invite et
c'est la première semaine de TPMP je
suis invité le vendredi et il y a un
gars qui arrête pas de me parler
mon bras droit
et là j'arrive sur le plateau et là il
faut que ce soit bon moi ils sont
foutait moi et donc ils disent des bons
il y a un truc ils disent il y a
Coldplay ce soir
[Applaudissements]
le feu en plus j'adore j'adore mais je
l'avais vu qu'à la radio donc voilà
bon l'ouverture du prime voilà donc
après voilà après 21h20 Nikos présente
le parrain de cette nouvelle promo de la
star acade c'est Robbie Williams alors
moi je me suis dit ils vont faire une
entrée avec Robbie Williams avec tous
les candidats voilà
le feu tout ça bah juste il était dans
sa loge en train de faire une vidéo
frère en plus il voit qu'il est le
prompteur il est attends alors c'est
quoi l'émission déjà c'est quoi morning
c'est quoi c'est LE MORNING sans filtre
Guillaume
il passe alors voilà regardez
vous présenter vous le connaissez tous
c'est une star internationale et c'est
aussi le parrain de la Star Academy 2022
bonjour C'est
Robbie
every malin
Robbie Williams prestige des élèves
franchement il va falloir être à nouveau
je vous mets un peu la pression et après
Robbie Williams ça veut dire on leur a
demandé combien pour cette mascarade
sympa les Français les gars essayez de
faire d'autres trucs avec eux j'ai
l'impression qu'on est sur des zombies
euh non mais bon voilà venir sur un des
prime l'équipe des produits viendra sur
un des points heureusement qu'il va sur
un des problèmes avec le billet qu'il a
eu
pardon pour le ressort de la star acte
avoir un parrain qui n'est pas j'aurais
dû mettre Jennifer quelqu'un qui peut
être là au moins physiquement
parce que c'est débile hein mais bon
voilà après bon après ils ont ça va il y
a pas il y a pas que des mauvaises
choses moi en vrai moi je kiffe pas la
Star Academy total mais les gens étaient
plutôt contents les gars arrêtez après
je voilà après voilà après voilà à 21h25
finir Mandal taille Kamel Ouali et Oscar
Sisto Nikos a présenté la nouvelle
équipe de prof et celui qui a fait
sûrement le plus réagir c'est Yanis
alors lui il nous présenter comme
histoire on dirait qu'il était connu du
monde entier ils ont même mis son nom en
lettre de feu derrière je n'ai pas
compris mais c'est qui Yanis c'est un
gars frère il y a eu un message pour le
gars tu étais un non mais je sais il est
tenté un parce que en fait il voulait
camel c'est pour ça qu'il est entêté
malheureusement quoi parce que les gens
voulaient Kamel ou donc il mettait le
nom de Denis surement très bien non mais
Yanis darka très darkalianisme
particularité parce qu'il en a une il
danse très bien en talon non mais c'est
vrai c'est comme ça qui s'est fait
connaître durant le gars tu le dis c'est
quoi ton talent dans un autre pays c'est
comme ça que c'est pas connaître ce
qu'il a fait incroyable talent en talon
en dansant talon c'est incroyable talon
[Musique]
voilà donc voilà donc Yanis c'était la
star du programme franchement mais bon
darka je trouve que c'est quelque chose
après je vous le dis la courbe elle est
comme ça parce qu'à un moment tu peux
pas je leur dis je leur dis tout je
pense qu'ils auraient fait beaucoup plus
s'il avait fait un autre conducteur
c'est à dire une autre un autre voilà
notre les séquences elles étaient pas
dans le bon ordre Yanis excusez-moi je
vous dirais dit que je l'aime beaucoup
mes médecins voilà c'est à dire
commencer par une danse comme ça de
quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas à 21h30
sur TF1 c'est une erreur stratégique
monumentale excusez-moi de dire ça et je
veux vraiment voilà je sais que
Jean-Louis il a pas été géré ça c'est le
grand patron mais en tout cas en dessous
je sais pas qui a fait des trucs mais
les gars tu peux pas tu peux pas mettre
un mec inconnu comme ça qui danse à 21h
qui avait 21h30 c'est bon non mais c'est
vrai je vous dis c'est pas possible
d'ailleurs la courbe elle est comme ça
là-dessus et et je l'adore mais il faut
attendre un petit peu faut laisser les
le temps de s'installer que les gens te
connaissent je sais pas ce que tu en
penses Mathieu bah effectivement et
d'ailleurs au Canada ils ont fait
différemment au Canada ils ont réouvert
après quelques années de pause à Tarak
vous aurez ouvert avec tous les gagnants
des séances précédentes c'était hyper
fort comme ouverture parce
qu'effectivement qu'il ne chanter avec
un des nouveaux candidats ils ont ouvert
avec de l'ancien et du achat et c'était
bien génial là évidemment elle était
devant oui c'est ça que j'ai pas compris
c'est quand on regarde la star on vient
quand même chercher de la nostalgie et
ça manquait d'anciens profs d'anciens
gagnants c'est ça que les gens viennent
chercher en revanche alors on peut
critiquer plein de choses avec le
plateau magnifique
le casting voilà en revanche par contre
on dit tout le temps que TF1 en galère
sur ses primes c'est vrai moi je pense
que ça c'est en ce moment ce qu'il faut
pour TF1 ça touche tout le monde c'est
un gros format c'est beaucoup d'argent
et on peut voir ça se voit l'argent
voilà franchement c'est autre chose que
ma singer ou dalles dit la vérité tu
vois l'argent le plateau il était fou il
y avait quand même des danses des trucs
après je vous dis voilà moi je pense
qu'il y a eu des petites voilà des
petits trucs à changer des petits
ajustements même sur la programmation
des chansons qui étaient un petit peu
voilà au début ça a pas de ça démarre un
peu poussivement
non non
c'était pareil mais il parlait pas
oublier le jury le jury la première fois
qu'il est venu sur la Star Ac à l'époque
personne ne les connaissait justement
regarder les profs et là et la prof de
chant super
[Musique]
tout le monde regarde
elle joue au piano et déjà c'est
vraiment voilà
amis là j'ai pris une petite claque
parce que je savais pas trop ce que
c'était son registre et j'ai adoré la
voir là-dedans
moi je suis fan de son timbre de voix je
trouve qu'il a atteint exceptionnel
merci beaucoup il se dégage de lui c'est
le bonheur d'être là le bonheur de
partager je crois que
alors la première candidate à chanter ça
a été lire la 24 ans elle vient de Paris
elle a interprété listen qui veut dire
écouter
sur les réseaux les gens écris qu'ils
avaient l'impression d'être dans The
Voice parce que le niveau était très bon
et c'est ce qui a été un petit pour
projet c'est à dire que le niveau était
trop beau regarde
[Musique]
son épique
typiquement elle chante très bien mais
c'est pas un tube ça on commence pas par
ça la première saison la star a commencé
par un truc qui envoie du très très
lourd où il y a une ambiance de fou et
où les gens vont se dire on connaît tous
la chanson c'est pas possible de
démarrer comme ça excusez-moi mais moi
ça me rend fou voilà je suis producteur
de l'émission je vois ça je me dis mais
qui a fait ça je l'appelle je lui dis
voilà tu vas rester chez toi excuse-moi
sans déconner c'est pas possible de
mettre ça je suis désolé tube rapide
d'ailleurs
c'est incroyable mettez un truc qui
envoie dès le premier mais tu as un truc
que tout le monde connaît je m'étais un
maître Gims mettez un kendji mettez un
truc qui envoie là tu mets les Nissan de
Beyoncé déjà tu t'endors tu sais pas
comment tu connais pas la chanson donc
tu étais comme un con elle est
complètement seule je trouve ça
poussiéreux et lent voilà c'était
lisseur
c'est toi quand tu fais l'amour
et vous le soulignez il y a un vrai
problème sur le casting on a
l'impression que tous ces jeunes là beau
ils sont déjà prêts pour une comédie
musicale c'est pas des vrais gens c'est
des talents
49 % sur les moins de 50 ans
on avait pris Jean-Pascal parce que
justement il savait pas trop
peu importe Jean-Pascal etc il y avait
la jolie fille il y avait la rigolote il
y avait le rigolo il y avait le
tire-au-flanc etc donc c'est c'était
aussi intéressant c'est pas intéressant
ça la candidate qui a ému tout le monde
c'est Annie chat
et moi je m'appelle
à la 22 ans elle a quitté sa terre
d'origine Madagascar hier il y a
seulement 7 ans
elle a rencontré dans son portrait avoir
vécu des moments difficiles elle a
interprété je suis malade et derrière
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé Serge Lama qui
l'a appelé en FaceTime encore une fois
que ce soit oui
c'est chiant quand même pour TF1
il est malin bien sûr
mais non mais ne parle pas comme ça
quand tu connais pas la situation
parisien ça n'a rien à voir et en bonne
santé
je m'appelle Annie chat je suis
originaire de Madagascar je n'ai pas
forcément eu une enfance facile c'était
difficile au point de vouloir quitter
mon pays Madagascar quand je commence à
chanter tout le stress toute la peur
tout ça
[Musique]
ne t'arrive on ne sait jamais quand tu
repars on le sait jamais sous et ça va
faire bientôt deux ans que tu t'en fous
alors voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est la
favorite elle chante bien voilà mais
c'est vrai que la choix des chansons les
mecs le samedi soir on a envie de ce qui
fait aussi là c'est un peu rasseral les
gars là les gars on va investissant
déconner on a l'impression d'être
surchan de France non mais oui non le
casting est très bon mais c'est vrai que
le niveau est très très haut et ça
manque d'élèves qui chantent pas très
bien le problème c'est que tu sais pas
qui est mais la star acade c'était
certes de la musique c'était aussi de la
téléréalité et la mine de rien c'est le
retour de la téléréalité d'enfermement
et ça manque de perso à la jambe Pascal
à la georin qui s'est constaté
ils sont tous très bien là mais c'est un
manga sing quand même et il y avait
Serge Lama en FaceTime immense artiste
c'est une légende Serge Lama voilà qui
était en FaceTime regardez
il est juste là
c'est Serge Lama
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui lui appartient c'est formidable
bravo merci
merci on vous aime Serge Lama
[Applaudissements]
c'est le oui je te cherche là-bas
il a fallu attendre alors là vraiment
mais comment tu peux faire ça je vous le
dis rayon de soleil tu faisais les 5
millions facile si tu mettais pas
Jennifer à 23h15 tu mets une meuf on
connaît pas et un gars qui danse qu'on
connaît pas pour l'instant qui est
extraordinaire mais tu les mets à 21h
dites-moi et tu mets Jenifer la star du
programme la plus emblématique du
programme telle que tout le monde
attendait à 23h15 les frères il faut
c'est du sabotage excusez-moi je vous
lis c'est du sabotage voilà donc je vous
adore voilà et voilà mais je vous le dis
on sait très bien marché heureusement
mais ça aurait pu encore mieux marcher
il y avait une grosse attente Jennifer
23h15 23h15 ma Jennifer même pas 23h15
23h16 regarder
donne-moi le temps
je le ressens j'abandonne
[Musique]
douceur et la fièvre
voilà alors elle est exceptionnelle dans
toutes ses prises de parole avec les
candidats
maintenant alors la soirée s'annonce
bien mais c'était sans compter sur les
bugs techniques puisque la régie de C8 a
été investie
je voudrais dire bravo parce que c'est
vrai qu'ils font un travail formidable
en vrai on en rigole mais il y a plus de
bugs sur ces
habitudes direct ils étaient pas en
direct il n'était pas en direct il n'a
aucune émission en direct il n'y a
aucune émission directe sauf TPMP
déjà il disait qu'ils étaient en direct
il ment toujours il faut plus qu'il le
dise ils n'ont pas le droit parce qu'ils
ne sont pas en direct ils ont un temps
de voilà
ils sont pas en direct
il peut se changer voilà et on veut
voilà on peut pas le voir regarde
des milliers de retour nouveau élève
mais toujours la même joie de musique de
super
[Applaudissements]
danger vous allez vous accompagner dans
le bus en fait c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
donne-moi c'est normal les vous avez
prévu plaisir j'ai pas entendu j'ai hâte
j'espère que tu sais danser
magnifique vous qui a dit j'entends pas
j'ai dit j'ai hâte j'espère que on va
s'éclater
et beaucoup de téléspectateurs se sont
plains que c'était pas du direct alors
Robbie Williams c'est sympa ça fait 10
ans qu'il voilà qu'on l'attendait
[Rires]
mais TF1 s'est rattrapé on a en exclu
les trois prochains par un de la
prochaine saison et c'est du lourd
regardez parce que apparemment il y aura
d'autres saisons regarde
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les élèves c'est Théo lavabo je
suis très honoré d'être le parrain
officiel de cette star academy 2023 je
suis désolé ce soir hélas je ne pourrai
pas être présent aussi le parrain de la
Star Academy 2024
bonjour CB vers frôlon qui vous parle je
suis très très honoré ce soir d'être le
parent de Star Academy 2024 voici le
parrain de la Star Academy 2025
salut c'est Zakaria aux stagiaire de
TPMP je suis ravi d'être le parrain de
cette nouvelle saison 2025 sachez que je
ne pourrai pas être là ce soir mais je
passerai vous faire un petit coucou pour
la finale
voilà et c'est donc Nico 5 qui reprenait
les reines de la Star Ac les loups et il
était voilà il était lâché voilà
regardez on vous a fait une petite
compile du style Nico regarde
des pâtes dedans
tu fais tout ça
me fait toujours plaisir Michael
l'ambiance dans le bus ça vous inspire
ça vous rappelle aussi votre jeunesse
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai dit ça
voici un garçon de 22 ans est-ce qu'il
se reconnaît il est où le garçon de 22
ans
il est pas sûr de t'as pas 22 ans tu as
quel âge a zen j'ai 20 ans dites-moi
tout je coach encore bah pour tout vous
dire je suis arrivé ce matin de Los
Angeles
à ce que vous êtes en tant qu'artiste
ici dans cette émission
j'ai pas bien compris la question
c'est vrai que c'est il venus vous
entendez dire c'était Maxime gaming
c'est la même animation que Maxime
j'adore ce qui est voilà il est il est
darka il faut savoir que cette saison
Nikos ne présente pas les quotidiennes
ils ont fait ça pour faire des écoles il
y a plein de gens qui a des surprises
pas le voir il est pas il va c'était
plus cher les séries on embrasse la
queue en Nico s'il était très ému de
retrouver la Star Academy château et
surtout une personne très très cher à
ses yeux regardez c'est le moment
émotion de Nico regarde
hallucinant
[Musique]
tu m'as manqué avec ton gros tas de
zikiki c'est ici que tout a commencé et
c'est dans ma culotte que tout va se
termine à nous deux je suis venu avec ma
chatte
[Applaudissements]
on nous a régalés toute la soirée sur
Twitter les internautes nous ont marqué
dès le début il y avait beaucoup de
Sosie parmi les candidats le casting
était assez stylé regarde
la première des choses qui se passe
est-ce que vous réalisez c'est
incroyable
moi je suis fan de son timbre de voix je
trouve qu'il a atteint exceptionnel
[Musique]
et parking parmi les candidats
particularité il faisait pas que chanter
il y en a qui se sont vraiment débarqués
ça a plus énormément au téléspectateurs
regardez
découvrez le candidat qui commence à
pleurer avant même d'avoir chanté c'est
énorme c'est un rêve j'ai rêvé de ça
depuis tout petit bonne chance dans un
instant vous allez chanter Louis la
candidate qui se croit dans N'oubliez
pas les paroles
[Musique]
le candidat fier de montrer qu'il a fait
anglais V2 j'ai trop hâte de rentrer
dans ce qu'un seul mon gars et enfin le
benjamin Castaldi de la promotion au
château le soutien et la respiration
pour que tout soit absolument juste
alors forcément les candidats quand ils
sont arrivés au château ils ont été
briefés pour ne pas dire des marques à
l'antenne donc ils ont tout fait pour
éviter et visiblement ça les a fait rire
regardez il donne pas les noms des
sodaseux
[Musique]
voilà c'était le retour de la Star Ac
les chéris voilà ce que vous avez aimé
tiens on va voir tout de suite ce qu'on
pense c'était les spectateurs le retour
de la Star Ac oui il y a 47%, non à 50 %
ils sont comme moi mon public me
ressemble aussi je suis michmich donc
voilà donc voilà voilà un peu plus non
mais